Thank you everybody for coming to
last morning sessions. Appreciate your attendance.
And
we have a nice program ahead here that will touch on some of the
biological and immune mechanisms of radioligand therapy,
which is an initiative here that we've got in linkage
with the AACR, and I think it's a perfect setting for
approaching radioligand therapy
mechanisms. Obviously, there's other societies and groups that delve deep
into the chemistry and the radiochemistry, also on the clinical
side,
applications that come along. But the AACR is a
perfect place to actually center ourselves on a deep
dive into some of the mechanisms and biological immune response.
So I'm going to start off with a little bit of immunological considerations of
radioligand therapy.
And then my colleague Mike Evans is going to look at some
new ways to look at a granzyme-targeted PET with some clinical
translation
work. And then Ravi Patel will finish up looking
at immunostimulatory radioligand therapy to enhance efficacy of
immunotherapeutic regimens. Again, I'll turn a little bit more to preclinical
data.
We'll go through each one of the talks sequentially for each about 20
minutes or so. And then,
we all plan to stay on time, and then we should have a good time for
about 20 to 25 minutes afterwards, sort of for a panel discussion
style,
question and answer session. So remember your questions if they come
up or write them down, and then we'll be happy to get a good dialogue going with
the audience afterwards. And
then we can also stay after if there's a good dialogue on
that.
I'd also like to point out this is going to be advertised now within the theme and
center of gravity of where we are right now.
The AACR Special Conferences has approved now a--
Oh,
that jumped there.
Has approved a cancer biology informed radioligand therapy special
conference, so we just want to make awareness about that, next
January, right here in San Diego at the Hilton San Diego Bayfront.
And this is all being done with the Cancer Molecular Imaging and Theranostics
Task Force of several colleagues here that are present on
that. So this will be a broad view through
radioligand therapy, but again, the center of gravity will be on cancer
biology informed mechanisms, and so that'll be a nice fit with the
AACR. So mark your calendars. We're looking forward to
hosting that conference here. So, a nice break to get down here in San Diego in
January for all the people in the north.
Okay, I'd like to look at here, explore a few concepts in
immunological considerations of radioligand therapy and priming immune
response. I do have some disclosures as mentioned
here.
As we all know, there are three main types of
radiation therapy. Of course, external beam radiation, IR.
About 60% of patients get this through rad onc
departments, external beam radiation.
Also insertional brachytherapy, where isotopes inserted into pledgets
and pills and little delivery
vesicles, and those can be delivered specifically in a cancer, especially in head
and neck and cervical cancer, these type of approaches.
And of course, what we're talking about today is actually injectable radionuclide
therapy. We want to emphasize that this is
different. This is molecularly targeted
radiation
that is fundamentally different than the local radiation with intent for
cure of traditional external beam radiation and insertional
brachytherapy. And also to remind ourselves that it's fundamentally
systemic because you've got the pharmacokinetics of a circulating
affinity ligand of some sort or another with an isotope.
And we are hypothesizing that that makes a difference in terms of the biological
mechanisms, and so we'll explore some of that.
Fundamentally, we think about radionuclide mechanism of action as starting with
ROS and DNA damage in sort of the traditional sense,
maybe traditionally single-strand DNA breaks with beta radiation,
double strand with alpha radiation, and maybe very
local double strand breaks with Auger electrons.
I think clearly there's some mix of that as we study this a little bit more.
And single-strand breaks can be converted to double-strand breaks, et cetera,
through DNA damage response within cells, fundamentally leading to maybe
apoptosis, necrosis, and ferroptosis, as well as immunogenic cell
death. And we'd like to concentrate on that.
What's the implications of that in terms of molecularly targeted
radiation and explore that concept a little bit more
deeply and mechanistically. Now, if we go back to external beam
radiotherapy and tumor immune response,
external beam is delivered locally with curative intent for
cancer,
but there's lots of activity going on outside the directed beam.
So it's well documented that external beam
radiation can be immune activating, traditional
X-ray therapy. It reprograms the tumor microenvironment.
There's been work looking at how it can induce immunogenic cell death and release
DNA, RNA, and PAMPs,
activates innate immunity, and may generate
neoantigens for presentation to dendritic cells.
Ultimately,
there's evidence that it can engage the adaptive immunity.
Often talked about as the abscopal effect,
responses outside the radiation field.
But when you talk to practitioners, that's actually pretty rare.
Everybody's got an example of it, but it's actually pretty rare.It's
also external beam radiation could be immune suppressive, and that's well
documented. It can recruit Tregs, and
MDSCs, and immunosuppressive
macrophages, sort of quote "M2-type macrophages,"
can actually induce increased expression of PD-L1 on tumor cells,
and induces immune checkpoint signatures.
So external beam
in relation to systemic radioligand therapy, the question is,
can radioligand therapy, because it's systemic, actually induce a more
prominent immune activation? That's sort of the fundamental query
of these investigations. So
when we look at that,
despite some beneficial immune activating effects, radioligand
therapy, as people are starting to look at the mechanisms, can certainly have
some suppressive effect. One of it is just simply the radiosensitivity of effector
cells by any radiation, especially
CD8 T cells and NK cells are highly radiosensitive, so we always have to
consider that. Crossfire is actually one interesting
aspect of especially beta radiation, but to some
degree alpha, the field effects of the radiation.
That could actually be an advantage with tumor heterogeneity.
As we know,
the heterogeneity of tumor antigens are well
documented, and in precision medicine, you kind of have to target the cell,
and one way to avoid that with traditional precision mechanism
and small molecules is lack of antigen
presentation. The field effect of radioisotopes, though,
actually can overcome some of that.
However, you can also have tumor-adjacent areas that are impacted where the
crossfire can actually damage incoming immune cells.
So it's sort of a two-edged sword that we're balancing in that.
And irradiated tumor cells also can generally release
signals to neighboring cells for
apoptosis or other responses. So the fundamental
hypothesis is that immunological benefits of
radioligand therapy,
can these be enhanced through radioisotope selection,
emission type, half-life, dosimetry, timing of
adjacent immunotherapy? There's a lot of things that we can do with
molecular targeted radiotheranostics above and beyond traditional
external beam. And indeed,
as we all know, these mechanisms and clinical translation of that
remains to be explored. So I'd like to drill down on two examples, some
work from our lab, and compare and contrast that from some recent work from
Zach Morris and his colleagues at University of Wisconsin to drive a few points.
We've, for several years, been developing a
antibody against B7H3, which is a highly attractive
pan-tumor target. Several ADCs are under development as we speak,
as well as
radioligand therapeutics. And that's because B7H3, a member of the
B7 family of immune checkpoint, but very complex
biology, ends up it's highly expressed in a wide variety of cancers shown
here with some immunohistochemistry.
Prostate cancer, breast cancer, colon, lung, gastric, but not expressed in
normal tissue, so it makes it a great radiotherapeutic
target,
and lots of activity going after that with ADCs as well as
some work by us and others with radioligand therapeutics.
And high expression of B7H3 has been
documented in the pathology literature years ago.
And here you can just see examples of a dozen different cancers that have high
expression of B7H3. So it's an attractive, quote,
"pan-tumor target" if successfully
engaged.
One thing about the structural biology to bear in mind, however, is that in
humans, there's two isoforms. There's the 4-Ig isoform and the
2-Ig isoform. And here's some AlphaFold 2 models of that.
These are type one membrane proteins, so they have
N-terminal extracellular domains with a single transmembrane domain and
a small intracellular domain.
And the 2-Ig isoform is two immunoglobulins in the extracellular
domain, a variable and a constant domain with a gene
duplication producing a
domain duplication for the 4-Ig, and many models
suggest that there's sort of a kink here, if you will, between the first
two and the second two pairs of immunoglobulins.
And so maybe that can be taken advantage, but there's actually then
structural evidence then of differences between these two isoforms.
Now,
this produces a confounder effect that in
humans you have the 4-Ig isoform
as well as the 2-Ig isoform, but
sheddases like ADAM10 can cleave that extracellular domain
and release the two into the circulation.
So there's a circulating two
as well as the target of the four. So the four
is the dominant isoform on cancers, but the soluble
two is circulating in the blood and can be a potential
pseudo target, in effect, a decoy or a sink that's not
widely appreciated that could really confound therapy.
And in the context of radioligand therapy, where we're
generally dealing with lower masses, this
circulating sink could be a problem.
If you're binding circulating two, you're not delivering to
the target four.
Bear in mind, mice only have the two isoform.
4-Ig is sort of human specific, actually,
guinea pigs, interestingly, pigs,
and monkeys also express it, but in terms of standard models,
you've got a human specific isoform, and it makes
the animal models a little bit more challenging.
But nonetheless, the goal is to say, could we develop a high affinity
4-Ig isoform specific anti-B7H3 targeting
antibody? So,Several years of work, just
want to point out that I'm going to describe then some of the properties then
of the murine MIL-33B, which is the mouse
4IG selective antibody. And we've now
humanized that, and we're translating that now into the
clinic. So I'm going to talk about today mostly the
preclinical work with the MIL-33B and mechanisms.
But indeed, the BetaBART, the humanized form of it,
has about 20 picomolar affinity for the 4IG isoform,
300-fold affinity for 4IG over 2IG
isoforms, and there's been some engineered reduced
affinities for FcRN into the Fc domain.
And
so we're excited that the Phase 1/2 trial with BetaBART has
just started with first-in-human enrollment and first patient injection in
late February. What we'd like to concentrate on today really is some of the
mechanisms around this in terms of immune response.
So jumping ahead here to some in vivo targeting.
So this is the MIL-33 antibody using standard
conjugation techniques with
zirconium-89 DFO,
MIL-33B. And here's some proof of targeting in vivo
with the 4IG-expressing human HeLa cells in a standard nude mouse model.
So HeLa cells are natural human cells that express high
levels of 4IG. And you can see in a flank model here,
very high localization in the tumor.
If we make a CRISPR knockout of B7H3 in the HeLa
cells, lack a target, you get no uptake.
Wild type with cold excess antibody, you get the classic in vivo
blocking. And the isotype control, whether it's in wild type
or CRISPR knockout cells, you get no localization, and that's all quantified
as tumor to heart ratio here, SUV ratios
on your right. So some nice localization as might be expected.
Here's now an immune competent BALB/c mouse.
And here we use the CT26 colorectal carcinoma murine
model.
And again, you could see injection of the
zirconium MIL-33B, nice localization.
As an antibody, you do see some liver as the excretion organ, if you will.
And in the control negative vector, you
see lack of uptake. And now remember, we had to transduce the
4IG B7H3 into the mouse cell line to introduce
the human target. So it is a transduced cell line, but the vector negative didn't
show a significant uptake, as well as the isotype control.
So that's kind of the model and the localization. Great.
Well, are we actually having therapeutic effect?
So again, we use the CT26, which bear in mind is
considered "immunogenic tumor model" because there
is some cellular infiltrate in that sense.
But it's also interestingly that it's IR-resistant
considered with standard therapy, IR-resistant murine colorectal
tumor. And here what we did was first
implant the transduced cell lines, and then at
about days 10 to 12,
we
administered a single dose of 100 microcuries of
the yttrium-90 beta emitting
MIL-33B, and here's our results. You could see that we
got significant long-term survivals with just a single
injection of 100 microcuries of the radiolabeled antibody with the beta emitting
yttrium-90. And of course, our controls, vector negative
control, injection of saline only are doing nothing.
Most of the animals died. So we could see that treatment of
established IR-resistant CT26 tumors with the
yttrium MIL-33B produced
56% survival with just a single injection
after 100 days. Now,
and on a little aside, it could be argued, well, you did have to
transduce the cells. Maybe the 4IG that you
introduced is a neoantigen that's stimulating the entire effect.
So we did some control experiments.
Here we did bulk RNA-seq on the murine CT26 cells of both
the transduced 4IG B7H3 as well as the CT26 empty
vector. And gene expression profiles revealed a
concordance correlation of about 0.98, so
between the transduced cells and the negative vector.
So we had proposed this data would not support that the
human 4IG is the dominant neoantigen.
It's the other neoantigens in the tumor itself that is driving the immune
response.
Similarly, we did some single-cell RNA-seq of extracted
B16-F10 equally transduced tumors,
another tumor model that we treated.
And here's the UMAP plots of the humanized transduced
4IG expressing B16 tumors versus control.
And again, they demonstrate strong concordance of both the identified cell types
as well as the numbers. And you can see
on the left versus the right under the UMAPs, very
identical overlapping signatures.
So again, we would say that these data do not support that the human
4IG that we had to transduce into the cells to present the target
itself was not the dominant neoantigen driving immune response.
And indeed, now, if we looked at midpoint tumors, we could see infiltrate of
CD3, CD4, and CD8 cells, and you can see the
staining here of some midpoint tumors that were extracted.
So the treatment was inducing cellular infiltrate, especially on
CD8 effector cells. And leading on that, we could now
actually look to see, was there engagement of adaptive immunity in the overall
response? So you're irradiating the cells with beta radiation at
the beginning, but what's happening downstream?
So in this case, we did immune depletion studies.
So if you inoculate and then do the injection,
100 microcuries at about days 10 or 11, but right
before the treatment and then on several treatments after that, we
used cell depleting injected antibodies.
And you can notice here on your right, the green line represents when we
pre-depleted... the CD8 cells, the
long-term survival completely went away.
But if we deplete CD4 cells
or just isotype control, we still got, in this experiment, about
30% long-term survivors. So clearly CD8s
have a major effect of engaging adaptive immunity for long-term
survival. Also, another characteristic of immune
engagement would be evidence of immune memory,
and here again, we treated the animals, and then we took
survivors at 100 days out. And now if you look
at that and reinject now the same tumors and
rechallenge now the survivors with the CT26
cells, you can see that the animals that were pretreated, the majority of them
now could reject the reinjected tumor, but if we took
age-matched treatment-naive animals, they all
died. They had no immunity
untreated against the tumor cells.
So that's evidence that the inoculated tumor cells that were reinjected
into the animals that were pretreated with radioligand therapy were
demonstrating now evidence of immunological memory.
In effect, there's sort of a secondary in situ tumor vaccination that's occurring
with the beta radioligand therapy.
And again, if you go and look very carefully at the responding tumors,
you can see the presence of CD4,
TCF1, TCF7, and CD8,
TCF1, TCF7 memory T cells. So that's one of the
characteristics of resident memory T cells is
the TCF1, and we could see evidence of that directly in the tumor
specimens. You might say, "Hey, this is an immune checkpoint antibody.
It's in the B7 family. Maybe the antibody itself is actually producing an
effect." So here's a control experiment with just cold antibody at
immune checkpoint levels, and this is very, very high levels of
MIL-33B. In fact, we only inject about 50 micrograms
during radioligand therapy. This is
32 times that amount. You're up into milligram quantities.
Bottom line, the cold antibody by itself as monotherapy has
no effect. All the animals die. So it really is the yttrium-90 that's
conferring the immunogenic response, not the
cold antibody itself in these model systems.
So I wanted to compare that to some recent work
from colleague Zach Morris at University of Wisconsin.
They just published some interesting work, and compare and contrast sort of
MIL-33B as a full-length antibody to a small molecule as
one example called NM600. NM600 is
basically a lysophosphatidylcholine analog, small
molecule that localizes to tumors,
and they used an MC38, also considered an immunogenic
colorectal carcinoma, different than CT26s that we use, but
very similar sort of overall characterization, and this just shows some
PET imaging with yttrium-86-NMD.
And interestingly, with this small molecule in these type of
tumors,
I want to point out the specific lines here with the red arrow, that either
yttrium-90 or actinium-225
NM600 by itself had no long-term survivors.
Very different than the antibody.
However, if they combined it with immune checkpoint, they actually did get quite a
few long-term survivors, and this was just recently published.
And interestingly, in this model, the yttrium-90 produced
a more efficacious effect when combined with immune checkpoint than
actinium-225.
Similarly to our data, the therapeutic efficacies are
dependent upon CD8 cells, so if you do the CD8 cell depletion, here's the
baseline, and you can abrogate that with anti-CD8.
So again, evidence of
immune effector cells of adaptive immunity being necessary for long-term
survivors.
And again, as tumor rechallenge, they also saw an effect here with
actinium-based NM600 plus immune
checkpoint. They could see some evidence on rechallenge.
Interestingly, about 50% fold compared to immune checkpoint in this particular
model, so not quite as robust as other models, but definitely there compared
to naive, as you can see.
This was interesting. They also looked at B78 immune-resistant melanoma
tumors,
and again, no long-term survivors with either yttrium or
actinium-225 NM600 as a single agent.
Again, single agent, no effect. But
when combined with immune checkpoint, they did see long-term survivors.
But interesting in this case, the actinium-225 was more
efficacious. So maybe some evidence that maybe
actinium-225 in the context of immune-resistant tumors
may help prime the immune system a little bit more.
We'll see if that's generalizable.
So overall, there definitely are immunological benefits of radioligand therapy that
are measurable
but highly complex. Radioisotope selection,
emission type, half-life, dosimetry, timing of
adjacent immunotherapy clearly will impact survival.
So I think we're only at the beginning of scratching the surface of immune
response and all the levers that we can push.
In this case and in these models, the full-length antibody
MIL-33B
that does contain an FC domain primes the immune system as a single
agent therapy.
Bear in mind that even at low to modest concentrations, the FC domains do
engage FCR receptors, and that may impact effector cells and immune
response. Interestingly, a small molecule example here, the
NM600, did not prime the immune system as
single agent, but only when combined with immune checkpoint,
and different isotopes, for instance, actinium-225, appeared to prime the immune
system differentially.
So this is sort of the working model I think that we can begin to think about.
Clearly, there's an initial effect of radiation, ROS
damage to the tumor cells, but then you've got immunogenetic cell
death, release of DAMPs, innate immunity will begin
recognizing that,
bringing
thoseActivating
the
local
antigen-presenting cells to begin engaging and presenting those
neoantigens that I think could be activating T cells, and effector T
cells can migrate back in. And the important point we want to think about then is
that there's a time domain that's very different for radioligand
therapy than traditional external beam.
External beam milliseconds. You're radiating,
and then you're looking at the follow-up after that.
Clearly, there's
protocols after that. But here, intrinsic to the
decay of the isotope, there's a half-life of the beta, the alpha
isotope or Auger electrons that's causing a
circulating cycle then of emissions, release
of DAMPs, circulating immune cells, et cetera, that are feeding back on each
other. And these are the details that I think are
different with radioligand therapy and provide mechanistic insight.
So I'd just like to acknowledge my lab group, and especially Seth Gammon, a
senior investigator at the lab for his great work, Sarah Glazer, a former
MD PhD student, and Margie Sutton, a senior investigator in the
lab for their great work for bringing this to fruition.
And I want to thank all the cores and thank you. Great. Okay.
Thank you very much. So we'll go on to our next presentation
here. Mike Evans will catch us up on
looking at granzyme activity. So great. Thanks, Mike.
Thanks so much, Dave. Outstanding talk.
So, we're going to come at this from a slightly different perspective.
So,
my lab has been making, I think, an opportunistic
contribution in this space. So we, just in full disclosure, don't
spend a lot of time thinking about combination therapy, but we do think about
tools that enable our understanding of the pharmacology of radioligand therapies.
And so we began a project,
that was really more about validating a platform, a certain type of delivery
mechanism of radioisotopes to tumors that I'll describe as we get into the slide
deck.
And the first
embodiment in the cancer space was really
an opportunistic play to see if we could actually image granzyme B.
And this takes us back many years ago to times in which molecular imaging tools
being developed for immunotherapies was all the
rage and is still a great unmet need.
And so what I'll show you is how,
just by being in a really outstanding collaborative environment at UCSF, we were
able to overlay that on a trial that was very systematically
testing the impact of Pluvicto on kind of
resetting the immune environment for prostate cancer to
allow subsequent responsiveness to pembrolizumab.
And so this'll span some chemistry, some mouse data, and then the most exciting
stuff, the clinical data, I think. So, these are my disclosures.
Like a lot of people in this space, I'm tied up in consulting and founding
arrangements. And so this is just a brief level set.
Very brief introduction on the radiopharmaceutical space and the IO
RLT question that I'll just gloss over because Dave did a fantastic job, and
then get into the meat of the talk, which is the actual design of
this molecule, what we're trying to do, how we're detecting granzyme, and
then the validation, the clinical data, and some concluding
remarks and some plugs on how we're trying to use this platform moving forward.
For many people in the room, I don't think this is really necessary to drill down
on. The nuclear medicine field is going through this huge renaissance.
You can measure it a variety of different ways,
with the increasing number of clinical approvals
since the field's founding, essentially back in the
pre-1950s,
the mergers and acquisitions, and then just the overall clinical revenues growing
in this space. I think a lot of what's driving this are chemical decisions.
Not entirely, but some chemical decisions, particularly with respect to how we're
trafficking radioisotopes to tumors.
As we started to think about things that are more drug-like in their properties, I
think this field's really taken off.
And so I'm highlighting the many different ways that we can traffic radioisotopes
to tumors for therapeutic purposes, these so-called radioligands, which we kind of
just slangly refer to as particularly low molecular weight things
that
achieve a therapeutic index by binding proteins that are differentially expressed
in tumor versus normal tissue. Not advocating for this over any of these other
approaches, but just saying that there was some inflection point associated with
a focus on radioligand therapy, going back a couple of years now.
But when we look at the kind of bottom-line clinical data, and it's evolving over
time as we deploy these in different clinical settings, but when you look at the
bottom-line clinical data that
has catalyzed this renaissance, particularly with examples like Pluvicto,
metastatic castration-resistant prostate cancer, the single agents are actually not
all that impressive in terms of our gold standard metrics like overall
survival. So PSMA 617 was approved with about a four-month
survival benefit. The radiographic progression-free survival was much more
extensive, but a four-month overall survival benefit.
Whereas anti-androgens, non-radioactive compounds like enzalutamide, apalutamide,
these were approved with a year of overall survival benefit.
And this is very confusing for the field.
I think a lot of people, myself included, struggle with this because nothing's
infinitely resistant to ionizing radiation.
We have mechanisms to pre-screen patients with PET scans.
Why is this happening?
So I think we're pushing this in a lot of different directions, just kind of
grossly binning them into two categories based on how I see the field and it's
evolving, or at least the most exciting directions which I think it's evolving.
One are optimizing RLT design, and I'm just shamelessly plugging a
figure from a recent review that we published in our reviews of cancer.
On the left-hand panel here, that's just trying to make the point that there's a
lot of different ways that we can do this through PK tuning or PD tuning, if you
want to think about it that way. And those are really focusing on the design of the
molecule itself. But you can also work within the space that you exist
right now, the clinical space, and just ask the question: Can RLT be
combined with kind of off-the-shelf, readily available standard of
care therapy or even experimental therapies that make sense
mechanistically? And this is just a table taken from Euro today from a Jeremy Clay
talk years ago,
showing the variety of different Pluvicto combination therapy trials that are
ongoing.The noticeable omission is the subject of
this talk, Pluvicto plus
immune stimulatory therapies. And so on this slide, I'm just highlighting
the concept behind a lot of clinical work that's going on at multiple centers right
now, but I think was initially kicked off in part by a single center study at
UCSF that I'll highlight in the next couple of slides.
Asking the question, can Pluvicto at a
subtherapeutic dose, meaning a single cycle at the therapeutic level
in terms of activity that we administer to patients,
can a single dose of that kind of reset the immune microenvironment,
and allow for responsiveness to single agent immunotherapies like
checkpoint inhibitors that we know when deployed just as monotherapies in prostate
cancer patients, generally are not very clinically active.
And so, there's been a single center study at UCSF that's been ongoing
for quite some time that's now expanded, that was organized according to the
following scheduled doses. Basically, playing with the
number of Pluvicto injections and the timing of the Pluvicto injections.
For example, with schedule one, it basically had a
pre-administration of lutetium 177
PSMA 617, followed by pembro chasers, if you will,
schedule two, concurrent administration with repeat injections, and then
schedule three, administering pembrolizumab first, and then following
with
the lutetium, essentially as a control arm.
The phase one data has been reported in "Lancet Oncology" and based on PSA
responses, there's measurable clinical activity for
the combination, particularly the
schedule one and schedule two patients.
And so this is not my study, but I do want to just highlight to set the context for
why we overlaid granzyme imaging onto this particular study, the main
deliverables from this study. And so these are key mechanistic insights from single
cell profiling and peripheral blood cells.
And so the punchlines appear to be that a non-ablative dose of
lutetium PSMA reprograms the immune landscape.
The immune effects of this are schedule dependent,
and it seems that CD8 T cell priming seems to
happen best with schedule one, schedule two, where lutetium is concurrent
or precedes pembrolizumab dosing rather than the reverse,
schedule three.
And when you look at the single cell data, you can actually see evidence
for enrichment of granzyme. And so all of this was kind of emerging
alongside our chemical development of the probe, and so we kind of had this happy
convergence of events where the phase one data was mature and
the mechanistic data was emerging at the time when our granzyme probe, which I'm
about to show you, was hitting the clinic.
And so it created this great situation where we were able to essentially use
this population almost as a positive control population for testing
if our granzyme probe works in patients, so to speak.
And so, the question we were fundamentally asking is, can you capture
granzyme B with molecular imaging? A lot of people are asking this question.
We're not the first to think of it. But can you capture granzyme B
degranulation from activated immune cells with this treatment
combination? So pulling all the way back to the start of this,
chemically, how did we achieve this?
So there's a lot of people have been making suicide inhibitors to granzyme probes,
and there's various different reasons why you might like or dislike that approach.
We came at it from a slightly different angle where we did not want to interfere
with the granzyme activity. We just kind of wanted to use it to activate and
unleash
something that was armed and detectable that would hang around at the site of
granzyme proteolysis. And so we worked with this platform that we call RIPs, which
is where the GRIP name comes from,
that are restricted interaction peptides.
And these are basically just
tumor conditional membrane inserting probes.
And by tumor conditional, I mean proteolytically activated.
So these are essentially just spaghetti noodle four kilodalton proteins that we can
cargo. They're organized into three domains, a latent
membrane binding domain in blue that we keep in a confirmation
that ignores membranes by coupling it to that red
domain. And then we can use proteases to recognize
the amino acids in the gray domain to conditionally separate blue from red, and
then you get membrane insertion more or less instantly.
And this was a technology that was developed by Charlie Craik as a molecular
imaging tool many years ago, and then we started repurposing for
oncology applications, both imaging and therapeutic.
And so our first cancer imaging endeavor in this space was to make this
granzyme probe, again, taking us back to about 2017 or so.
The theory was is that
we want to see immune cells when they're activated specifically for
very specific
basic research and potential clinical applications, rather than just kind of
tracking the abundance or distribution of immune cells in the body.
So the hope was is that we could catch granzyme as it's being
degranulated and pushed through the pericellular space from immune cell to
cancer cell, because if that's happening,
they are certainly activated, and there's possibly even a chance that they're
working on the cancer cell to kill it.
And so the idea was that, we'd administer this granzyme probe, which is not cell
permeable, and it would capture the bolus of
granzyme that's floating in between the cells, cut, stick, and stay, and there you
go.
So to achieve that, we applied some mass spectrometry that I won't get into,
basically to identify a very efficient and specific granzyme sequence
because I'm sure as many of you know in this space, anything protease, just like
kinases, comes with specificity challenges.
So if you're trying to make a biomarker, you really have to put in the labor to
make it specific, or it's just going to be very confusing on the back end.
And we think we achieved that using mass spectrometry approaches that I can talk to
you about offline that are kind of beyond the scope of the talk.
We can arm these things with a variety of different cargos.
For the nuclear imaging purposes, we chose DOTA,
and ultimately ended up working a lot with copper 64, though we've done other
things. The membrane inserting portion is a peptide from a frog,
an antimicrobial peptide that adopts a helical conformation, just kind of snuggles
in the membrane. It doesn't rupture like bee venom.
And we thought that was important for imaging applications.
If you put this copper 64 probe in a mouse with a tumor, with no
immune activation, you just urinate it out, as you would expect for a
kilodalton peptide.We've done a series of studies that were
pioneered by others, where you take mice with syngeneic tumors that have no
immune responsiveness, blast the mice with immune checkpoint inhibitors to rev
up the immune system, then flow in the probe.
And when you do those studies, you can see that
tumors that are experiencing immune response because of treatment,
activate the probe and retain it for an extended period of time, which I'm showing
on the top left panel, and then autoradiography confirms
that. Biodistribution, if you measure it in terms of percent change of
radiotracer uptake, shows that tumor is among the highest organs in which you see a
percent increase in granzyme probe uptake, but you also see it elsewhere in the
body, like in the spleen, which we think is an important application of imaging.
These are just simple control studies.
If you put in a D-amino acid and you kill the ability of the probe to be
cut by granzyme B, nothing happens.
When you immune stimulate mice, and if you run all these studies in granzyme B
germline mice, you also don't see any treatment effects.
And if you like these types of studies, we can make correlations between SUV and
eventual tumor responses, though I think that's a little squirrely when we're
talking about mice with subcutaneous tumors.
But we do see a correlation that suggests that the magnitude of granzyme uptake
at an arbitrary time point post-injection can be predictive of eventual
tumor response.
But getting back to the more interesting clinical data.
So we translated this molecule about two years ago into patients.
We've have a couple of cohorts that are concurrently accruing.
Cohort A is just a standard run-in dosimetry cohort, first in human,
PK safety, and dosimetry. And then Cohort B is a GU
population where we're looking at imaging pre and post standard of care checkpoint
inhibitor with any other combination. And Cohort C is the one that we'll focus on.
That's the metastatic castration-resistant prostate cancer cohort, the PLUVICTO
plus the pembro chaser.
This is just a little bit of box checking safety data here, just showing that,
in a patient with no disease, this molecule basically just clears
through the kidneys, and we have a little bit of liver-associated activity, which
we think is more about copper than it's actually about
the probe itself. When you look at the dosimetry, neither are
particularly troubling. They're very low, and we've got a nice blood curve,
as you would expect.
So this is what our GRIP imaging looks like.
So we overlaid GRIP imaging in these Schedule 1 and Schedule 2 patients, but
mainly Schedule 2. We're administering the dose of
PLUVICTO prior to the start of the granzyme
imaging and then following and adding the granzyme imaging in wherever we could
slot it in alongside with the KEYTRUDA.
So in this one very nice case study, actually the first patient that we imaged,
this patient came on the study in January of 2024, had
triple-digit PSA, 21 bone avid lesions on
PSMA PET, qualified for the study, a single dose of PLUVICTO,
multiple doses of KEYTRUDA between January
and April of 2024, had a 90% PSA response.
April 2024, we give him this granzyme PET, and we lit up eight of his
boney
lesions on this granzyme PET scan.
When we did a follow-up PSMA PET scan on this particular patient, all of the things
that we were lighting up on the granzyme scan are still cancer.
So we can still see the PSMA present.
So these are not
reactive normal structures.
And what was really interesting with this patient is that as he continued his
journey from April to August of 2024,
he experienced another PSA decline.
So he went from 90% to about 95%. And on the
follow-up granzyme scan, we saw two interesting things.
One is we saw an intensification of SUV of all the original eight lesions that lit
up in April, which is consistent with a progressive response.
And
we also saw the appearance of new lesions that did not show up on the April
scan. So granzyme
photopenic lesions in April were now lighting up beautifully in the
August scan. All of which is kind of consistent with his PSA narrative and his
overall clinical experience.
And again, these new lesions were very
clearly cancer based on a kind of a PSMA
PET sanity check.
We've seen similar things in other patients, and I'm not going to go through all
the show and tell and everything, but the point is that this is not an N of one
experience. So this is another patient, scored very well on PSMA PET
scan, qualified for the combination therapy study.
And this patient had granzyme avid lesions, both on his
first scan, which came after an initial dose of PLUVICTO plus some
pembro, and then also had this evolution experience that we saw in
the first patient. So the scan one, scan two here is referring to the actual
granzyme scans. And so the granzyme scans here are separated by
about two months. The first scan, you can see some examples of cherry-picked
PET avid lesions, and then the second scans are showing either
intensification or appearance of new lesions that weren't obvious on the first
scan.
Okay, so for this imaging section, I'll just conclude by saying,
we think we're onto something. I mean, as much as you can tell you're onto
something with a PET scan, it's obviously very difficult with clinical studies to
interrogate what's actually happening mechanistically with the PET scans.
But we see, I think, a very compelling
correlation between PET avid lesions and other orthogonal
clinical features of response in a patient population that we came
into knowing a little bit about it, mechanistically.
We knew that these patients were already having PSA responses, or a subset of them
were having PSA responses, in studies that predated our
imaging correlate studyAnd we also know from the
peripheral blood cell profiling that there's evidence for granzyme
B induction, because there are some questions about the relevance of granzyme B to
all of this versus other granzyme species, et cetera.
To the quality of the probe, I think it's very important that we're actually
not seeing uptake in a lot of tumors.
So I'm showing you examples of patients where there is uptake.
We have many more examples of
patients where there's zero uptake in the tumors, regardless of whether they're
having a clinical response or not.
And then we have this compelling case of intratumoral
heterogeneity within the same patient.
And we don't know what that means, but that kind of gets back to the whole point of
why we advocated for molecular imaging originally in the first place.
Like, why are you doing this? Because you're uncovering information that you
probably couldn't get with
blood-based biomarkers.
A question I get asked a lot is, how do you know when to run the granzyme scan?
And the answer is, we don't know at all.
So these studies are being organized based on a
criteria and windowing that we provide in the protocol, obviously, but it's also
kind of when you can get the patients.
And so some of the reason why I think we're having success in this patient
population is because I think the response is actually kind of continuous and
slowly evolving, rather than a dramatic response like in a CAR
T population
or lymphoma population receiving CAR T, or in maybe
a non-small cell lung cancer melanoma population where the responses can be
very dramatic and the dumping of granzyme B may happen maybe just a day or two
after the initiation of treatment for those patients that are going to respond.
And that's something that I've had hallway conversations about other people in this
space,
because we're all kind of struggling with why aren't we seeing more
compelling granzyme responses in more patients more quickly
as we roll these things out.
We do occasionally see uptake in patients that are not receiving IO.
So I'm just highlighting a sarcoma here, in which we receive very high levels of
uptake, and we have no idea why, but it's very rare.
Generally, the uptake is associated with some sort of ongoing IO
experience. And we're pushing this probe in other populations.
My last little plug is that we, I think as
many of you know in this room that have seen me give talks, we spend a lot of time
thinking about differentiated therapeutics.
And part of the reason why we developed this platform is because we were also
interested in trying to see if it was a very useful way to traffic
radioisotopes to tumors, because the mechanism kind of feels like a little
radio iodine-ish, FDG-ish in the sense that you have a two-step
mechanism, right? A non-saturable
step that kind of gets you to the tumor, and then a second step that keeps you in
the tumor. And so, we have enzymes that are activating these probes and membrane
insertion that's more or less irreversible.
And we hope that that'll give you therapeutic index expansion in the form of higher
tumor AUC on a per injection basis with equivalent
background to competitors like low molecular weight radioligands.
So we've developed RIPS to that end, and we've benchmarked against things
like FAP. And what we've been able to show with RIPS against
FAP is that they
light up FAP-positive tumors, they ignore FAP-negative tumors.
And when we do these benchmarking studies against RLTs that aren't exactly straw
men, like FAP p46 or FAP2286, we
do see
a very significant improvement in tumor AUC compared to
just kind of garden variety RLTs. And we think that has a lot to do with renewable
catalytic activation of these things in the tumor, rather than
stoichiometric binding, and membrane insertion instead of protein binding.
And so we're working to flesh this out therapeutically as part of a
collaboration with UCSF NUCO that we call TherApain.
And so with that, I will stop and thank everybody for their time, and happy
to take questions during the panel session. Thank you.
Great. Our last speaker will be Ravi Patel.
And we're right on time. Thank you very much.
And then when we're done, we'll have a panel question and answer discussion.
Thanks. All right, Ravi.
Thank you. So I'll
thank the organizer, NCR, for giving me the opportunity to present some of our work
on combination treatments of RLT and
immunotherapy.
These are my disclosures.
And so, as a radiation oncologist, whenever I talk
about radiation immunotherapy, the first question I get asked about
is, do I believe in the abscopal response, or what do I think about it?
And the abscopal response is something that's been reported,
and we talked a little bit about earlier, where we radiate
one site and there's a response at a distant site.
In the era of immunotherapy, there was a lot of interest when these immune
checkpoint inhibitors first came out that we may see more
abscopal responses, but historically, it's
a rare phenomenon.
There's many ways by which radiation can help enhance
efficacy of immunotherapy. It can deplete immune suppressor
cells such as Tregs or MDSCs. It can stimulate
cytokine release. It can increase immune
infiltrate, cause immunogenic cell death, and then cause
phenotypic changes in cells surviving radiation.
And all of these can depend on the time, dosing, and fractionation of
radiation.
Preclinically, we've long had data showing that radiation
therapy can enhance efficacy of immune checkpoint inhibitors.
An early study by Andy Minn's group at Penn showed that
radiation,
when added to anti-CTLA-4 or anti-CTLA-4 and PD-1,
improved survival in mice with B16 melanoma
tumors. These radiation increased
TCR diversity as well as clonal frequency.And this
led to the idea that radiation can potentially work as an in
situ vaccine for a precise immuno-oncology approach.
However,
prospective trials, this has been tested in multiple studies, have
been mixed at best. Largely, many
of these studies have been negative when we add immunotherapy
just to conventional chemoradiation.
Notably, some studies in head and neck
showed that if we do chemoradiation as we typically do for head and
neck and add immunotherapy, we didn't really see much
benefit. So there's some discordance between our preclinical and
clinical data.
Many of the effects of radiation are localized, especially when we're thinking of
external beam radiation,
where we treat a local area. We see
that depletion of suppressive
lineages, antigen presentation,
integrin expression, those are all local to areas that
we irradiate. So the question
we asked was, can we deliver immunostimulatory radiation to all
sites of disease?
So targeted radionuclide therapy, or RRT, has been around for
quite some time. We have our targeting agent with the
radioisotope. And
while these agents have been present for a long time, there's been barriers
to development.
We've had iodine-131 for a long time, but we don't
have those perfect targets for most of our solid tumors.
So because some doses always deliver to normal tissues, we have to
worry about therapeutic index, especially when our solid tumors
require quite high doses for monotherapy
eradication.
So
the question I asked when I was starting my postdoc was,
can we use lower doses of TRT with immunotherapy to have a higher
therapeutic index?
The first speaker mentioned, as I started
working on NM 600, which is alkyl phosphocholine, has specific
uptake in multiple types of tumors through lipid rafts.
But
my early work was focusing on B 78 melanoma,
where we show specific uptake. We also showed that
there's penetration to the
CNS with glioma models, and importantly, that
compared to free isotope, we do have good tumor targeting.
Importantly with this agent, at low doses, it did
not cause systemic lymphodepletion.
We didn't see depletion of our systemic lymphocytes.
And with relatively modest activity
levels, 50 microcurie, we had
about two and a half gray delivered to the tumor.
So the first experiment and question we looked at
was how do we combine this TRT agent with immune
checkpoint blockade?
Unlike external beam, targeted radionuclide therapy delivers dose
continuously, and we wanted to deliver RRT over a short
time to prime immune response, remove suppressive cells, but not
blunt our effector response.
So, in a B 78 model, we
varied our dose of TRT from 25 microcurie to 100
microcurie, and we see that with
50 or 100 microcurie corresponding to two and a half to five gray
of tumor dose, we improve survival.
And actually, we had about a 50% complete response rate in
this model, showing that this
combination has a synergistic effect.
With just immune checkpoint blockade alone or TRT alone, we really didn't
have that survival improvement.
We also, when we looked at the tumor microenvironment,
found that if this combination of TRT
plus immune checkpoint blockade,
I mentioned that about 50% of mice had complete response and the
50% of mice had
tumor progression. We see in our responder mice that they had
higher levels of cytokines within the tumor microenvironment,
with the notable exception of IL-10, which is sometimes thought to be
immunosuppressive.
And this shows that this combination can potentially turn a tumor that's
not responsive to checkpoint blockade or cold into a more hot
tumor.
This is work done by my colleague, Rainier
Hernandez.
He used lutetium NM 600 monotherapy,
and he looked at the 4T1 breast cancer model
as well as the 4T07 model, which is a precursor
that does not metastasize. And what he found was that
as you increase dose in the non-metastatic 4T07
model, you have improved tumor control.
He had long-term complete responders.
But when he injected those same activities
into the 4T1 model that spontaneously
metastasizes, he did see primary tumor response, but not
an improvement in survival because these mice developed
micrometastatic disease, showing that monotherapy,
at least in some of these cold tumors,
can control primary bulky disease but may not be able to control
micrometastatic disease.
On the other hand, when we did much lower activity
in doses of
a Y 90 NM 600We did see
that when we combined with checkpoint blockade, now in that 4T1 model,
we were able to control both primary tumors as well as these
micrometastatic sites. And we saw a reduction in the
micrometastatic disease, suggesting that
for
tumors and micrometastatic disease,
this combination of targeted radionuclide therapy plus checkpoint blockade
may provide better efficacy.
We also looked at what the effect of radiation field size is.
So if we're giving two and a half gray, we can give that
to the whole patient or a whole mouse
without significant toxicity. And so we compared two and a
half gray to the tumor alone, two and a half gray to the whole mouse,
or two and a half gray delivered systemically via TRT to
the tumor while avoiding
immune-rich organs.
And so what we saw was that if we gave external beam to the tumor plus
checkpoint blockade, we had an enhancement of tumor response.
But if we gave two and a half gray to the whole mouse, we lost that effect.
Again, if we gave two and a half gray with TRT systemically,
but dose being delivered to the tumor, again, we saw that reestablishment
of that
anti-tumor effect, suggesting that delivering
equivalent RT dose to the whole body causes
loss of therapeutic effect.
And when we deliver radiation to the whole mouse, we
do
deplete systemic lymphocytes. And we see that if we
deplete CD4 and CD8s,
we lost efficacy of this combination of this TRT plus
checkpoint blockade.
And we did another study where we looked at full-length
GD2 antibody.
These melanoma tumors have a high expression of GD2.
And what we found was that this GD2
antibody did not have a synergistic effect with immune
checkpoint blockade compared to small molecule, even though with this
GD2 antibody, we delivered a much higher dose of
radiation to the tumor. But as we see with the
full-length antibody, which has a long circulation, they have a depletion of
lymphocytes while the small molecule didn't.
Suggesting that when we're thinking about combinations with immune checkpoint
blockade, we do need to think about what it's doing to the systemic
lymphocyte compartment.
So when I left to join the
University of Pittsburgh,
I started a collaboration with Carolyn Anderson, who had a graduate student.
She was leaving, so he came to join my lab,
and he was interested in doing work with LLP-2A, which
binds VLA4,
and combination immunotherapy.
And when Mike was doing this work, did many studies,
but he just wasn't seeing the synergy between
LLP-2A and dual checkpoint blockade.
And one of the issues Mike was coming across was that VLA4 is
also expressed on immune cells, lymphocytes, and myeloid cells,
causing systemic lymphodepletion.
So we took that project, and lymphodepletion
isn't great in the context of immune checkpoint blockade from our
findings, but it could potentially be beneficial for cellular therapy where
we have lymphodepletion regimens.
Radiation has also been shown to be effective
as a bridging therapy for CAR T-cell therapy.
It can induce antigen cross-presentation and
increase expression of CAR T receptors.
So I started a collaboration
with Rosa Nguyen at the NCI, who has done a lot of work in CAR T-cell therapy, as
well as Freddy Escorcia. And we looked at
VLA4 targeting radionuclide therapy as a
conditioning agent for adoptive T-cell therapy.
And we showed that
this VLA4 target is overexpressed in multiple
types of liquid and solid tumors, both pediatric and
adult.
We also validated surface expression across multiple
mouse and human cell lines
and show that there's
high expression in multiple types of tumors.
We then did some imaging and dosimetry.
We used the B16 model,
as well as some melanoma models and breast cancer models, showing that there
is high tumor uptake and
dose delivered, as well as to immune-rich organs where we are trying
to lymphodeplete, such as the spleen, thymus,
and marrow.
So
we then
asked the question: Can we increase engraftment with better systemic
lymphodepletion compared to standard Flucy regiments?
So we engrafted
CD45.1 T-cells into wild-type
CD45.2 mice, and we see that when we add
copper 67 LLP-2A
in addition to Flucy, we have increased engraftment of our donor
cells as well as retention of our donor
T-cells.
We then used the B16 PMel model,
where
the B16
GP100 model expresses the tumor marker GP100, and
the PMel mice have T-cells that can recognize and
attack GP100. And what we found
was that when we added copper 67 to Flucy conditioning,
we have improved tumor response, improved
survival.In addition, when we have
deeper conditioning in these PMEL
B16 models,
showing that this lymphodepletion conditioning with RLT can
provide a benefit.
We also wanted to look at how
VLA4-targeted LP2A can modulate the tumor
microenvironment.
So,
in NSG model, using SK-N-AS
neuroblastoma,
we
compared different doses of copper 67 LP2A
plus B7-H3 targeted CAR. These cells overexpress
B7-H3. And what we found was that there was a
significant improvement in survival as well as complete
responses with five out of seven mice when we added
copper 67 LP2A to our
B7-H3 CAR versus
no mice in the CAR alone or
CAR plus or LP2A alone, showing that there's this
good combination,
that this combination can help
improve CAR T-cell efficacy.
We also looked at this in orthotopic models of
neuroblastoma. Again, the same B7-H3 CAR
T-cell model.
We showed that there is
improved cure rates and complete responses when we add copper
67 LP2A compared to CAR T-cell therapy alone,
and much lower tumor
weights.
We also did some sequencing to look at some
mechanisms by which copper 67 LP2A
can affect the tumor microenvironment.
So, this was just in vitro cell culture studies.
We see some differences between mesenchymal
versus adrenergic neuroblastoma.
So in our
mesenchymal models, we didn't really see much in the
change of cytokine levels. But in our adrenergic, and also
our recent findings, P53 wild type, we see
increased TNF alpha and activation of the
NF-kappa B signaling pathway, suggesting that this
cytokine
secretion may affect efficacy of our CAR T-cells.
We also looked at exhaustion markers as well as
looking at the different types of immune cells in our tumor
microenvironment with single-cell sequencing.
And what we found was that when we gave copper 67
LP2A plus our CAR, we see reduced expression of
exhaustion markers such as TIM3, LAG3, PD1.
With our CAR alone, we see much higher
levels of four exhaustion markers,
and very few
T-cells that don't have exhaustion.
While now if we gave copper 67 pretreatment, we see in the white that we
have an increased proportion of T-cells that don't have any
exhaustion markers, and very few that are maximally exhausted with
multiple markers. We also found that
there's increased CD3 infiltrate as well as central memory
T-cells with copper 67 prior to CAR
infusion. And when we looked at our
single-cell sequencing data, we see in the
yellow and orange increased CAR-positive
T-cells,
with copper 67 treatment. And importantly, if we look at this black
box here, with CAR alone, we see a high percentage
of tumor-associated macrophages with M2 or suppressive
phenotype and much lower levels of those
suppressive tumor-associated macrophages if we pretreat with
copper 67 LP2A.
We also performed co-localization studies
with immunofluorescence. And we see that
in both our IMR 5 and SK-N-AS models,
adrenergic and mesenchymal neuroblastoma,
we see that these CD8 positive cells
that
co-localize
with--
our CAR-positive cells
co-localize into these tumor niches.
We see increased expression of
CD8 cells with granzyme,
and we see fewer tumor-associated macrophages.
So, conclusions and future directions.
Low dose. We can use relatively low doses of targeted
radionuclide therapy to deliver immunostimulatory radiation.
It can enhance efficacy of various types of
immunotherapy, both immune checkpoint blockade as well
as cellular therapies.
When we're thinking about immune checkpoint blockade,
some of our data shows that it's important to spare systemic lymphocytes.
However,
if you do have an agent that does deplete systemic lymphocytes,
it may be useful for conditioning with cellular therapies.
Some of our future work that we're doing, we're doing
preclinical validation of TRT plus CAR T-cells in different
types of tumor models, including breast cancer, AML,
and others.
And
we're trying to translate some of this neuroblastoma work into the clinic
with our pediatric oncology collaborators.
So I'd just like to thank my lab, and
happy to answer questions as part of the panel.
Great. Thank you very much, and thank you, speakers. We're right on time.
So, yeah, we've got about 20 minutes for some open
discussion and dialogue to the panel.
So any questions that you might have, just step up to the
microphone, and we can get a dialogue going. Thank you.
It was a great session. Thanks to all of you for great talks.
John Babich from
Raysearch Therapeutics in Boston. First question for David.
David, have you tested-- First of all, I take
issue with it's a single agent. I think your antibody labeled
with an isotope may be doing two things simultaneously.
One is blocking B7H3 from its immune role
and delivering radiation. Have you looked at the cold antibody
with external beam radiotherapy on the tumor?
And,
does it have the same effect as the labeled antibody itself?
Let's see where to turn this on.
I guess it's activated. Yeah. Okay. Very well. Hey, great. Thank you very much.
Actually, we have not. There's just so much to explore, and a lot of our focus has
been on the radiotheranostic.
But in also some other cell-based assays, we were
interested early on with this
antibody, if it had any sort of immune checkpoint
kind of properties, and looking directly at ADCCs
and such. And we didn't observe any.
So it's a tight binder, but for sort of
standard assays, it's not interfering with ADCCs or some of
the other immune functions.
But in combination, as you described, we haven't done that experiment.
That's an interesting idea.
No, it's a very attractive approach, right? To hit two things simultaneously.
Yeah. And also, we always remind ourselves with any antibody, and I kind of
touched on it, is you do have the back end. You've got the FC.
It could either be wild type or in the ADC world, mutations are introduced
into there for both efficacy or for blocking
FCRN
activities.
But,
you have both the front end, your CDRs, as well as the FC, and
even at low mass, there might be some low levels of engagement, sort of
analogous to what Ravi's describing.
Low biological effects that in some might
have
added components to the efficacy. So, that's worthy of exploring.
And of course, that's unique then to full-length antibodies.
Nanobodies, peptides, other small molecules, that would be a different world.
But to that point, what's the affinity of that antibody? Is it picomolar?
Yes, it is. This particular one, the humanized antibody beta BART that's now in the
clinic, it has about 24 picomolar for the
4IG isoform and about 350-fold
selectivity for four over two.
Just one general comment. I think we're going to see this field evolve as
combinations, right? We just have to get a lot more
experience with combining radiation with all these immune checkpoint and when
to do it, and the
sequence is going to be critical.
My next comment is to Mike.
Very nice talk again.
When we look at the granzyme B, as you know, we're in that space a little bit.
And you look at the lack of sort of profound response when you
see apparently T cell activation in these patients.
I wonder if you've done-- In post-PSMA therapy, there's a lot
of reduction in tumor burden.
I don't know, that's not T-cell. I would think it's macrophage.
There's other white blood cells coming in and cleaning up dead
prostate cancer cells. One question I think for the
granzyme players is, are we seeing
other enzymes basically activating these compounds and
grabbing them? I like your approach with having that little tag that sits in the
membrane. But there may be enough proteases that
get spit out from all these different white blood cell populations that you just--
Most of those things are concentration dependent, so if you have enough of them,
you may actually chew it up. I'm just curious as to what, if you've looked
at just any other macrophage,
white blood cell, attack on tumors, and whether or not you
get any binding.
Yeah. That's a great question. In a
focused way, not in a global proteome sort
of way. So,
the nice thing about granzyme B is as far as proteases
go, it's pretty specific. It's just evolved to be pretty
specific with the aspartic acid in the P1 position.
But caspases are the obvious thing you worry about, right?
And exactly to your point, if you're on chronic or
acute treatment and you just have detritus in the tumor
microenvironment,
are you accidentally imaging caspases?
And so we focus on that. We focus on other things that we think
have potentially granzyme-like
biochemical activity,
ex vivo. And in simple ex vivo
experiments, when we spike in these recombinant enzymes at very high
concentrations, there's remarkably little activity.
But there's limits to what we can simulate, exactly to your point,
which is why I kind of couch some of the clinical data.
It's tough for us to know mechanism.
We have signals, and the signals align with other clinical correlates.
But, right. Yeah, it's very tough to know mechanism, and I'm
cautiously optimistic that this will be an instructive assay.
I think it'sI think it's a lot of information gathering at this point.
I'm a little confused about some of the
comments I was making during the talk.
Why are we not seeing more granzyme signals just fall out of the sky?
In patient populations where we know that these things are happening.
But to
pull back from the rant and get back to your question more specifically, the best
piece of in vivo data that we have for specificity is that germline granzyme
B knockout study,
where we take CT26, MC38, whatever, pop it
into mice, blast them with immune checkpoint inhibitors, flow in our probe, and
we see nothing.
Because we can control that, gate that study where we know tumor responses are
happening. There should be caspase spillage, at least within the tumor
microenvironment.
I don't think it lasts very long, but there's plenty of opportunity for lack of
specificity in an experiment that is so heavy-handed,
and we don't really see much. But your point is exactly taken.
There's just certain biological niches where you always have to tiptoe around
because specificity is concerning and certainly proteases are one of them.
The last comment, there's a company called Nordic Bioscience, I think in Denmark,
that has blood-based assays for granzyme B activity.
You may want to take a look at them. We've been talking to some colleagues at
Memorial Sloan Kettering about a FAP-related and
blood-based readout, and
talk to them about that as well. Whether or not you have blood samples from the
patient population in that trial is whether you go back and look at what the
granzyme B activity, it's through some collagen
metabolism profile.
Yeah.
Might be worth a look. Thanks.
Yeah. Awesome.
Hi, Rob Godin from AstraZeneca. So again, that question around
the correlation, looking at the granzyme B, have you correlated that to the PSMA
PET imaging as well to understand if that's correlating?
Only insofar as we're doing a sanity check with the way
the study is structured right now.
We're doing a sanity check to make sure that the things that we're seeing that are
granzyme positive are still tumor.
Yeah.
And they don't have to be, but you would expect that
they likely would be, given the rate at which prostate cancer
tends to collapse against any therapy, which is to say slowly.
But
the study that you're describing, basically,
maybe not a head-to-head comparison, but parallel tracking of PSMA
responses on PET to therapy alongside
something that's functional in a different way, granzyme PET, is certainly on our
radar. I think the
main issue for us right now is scale.
We just need to get more patients on the scanner and more positive
signals on the granzyme scan to kind of catch up with where PSMA
is right now.
But yeah, it's a great idea. We've gone from
molecular imaging
assays, clinical-stage molecular imaging assays for prostate cancer to being
very primitive 20 years ago to where we are today, where there's kind of like an
embarrassment of riches. So
yeah. But your point's very well taken.
So certainly, these are things that we're doing in mice,
and
for what it's worth, but yeah.
Basically, we don't have enough data points right now and enough time point
sampling to get at that question, but it's definitely on our radar, and
we're happy. Part of
looping in TheraPain is not shameless self-promotion, but to make the point that
the technology is outside of the university, but also still kind of inside the
university. So there's multiple ways for us to collaborate with partners to deploy
this technology to start answering some of these questions to the
extent that a partner would want to answer the questions.
That's pretty fascinating. Also wondering, too, maybe have you looked at anything
with a combination, like a radioligand with a DER inhibitor or something, and
would that increase perhaps
an immunogenic response or not?
Yeah. These guys are probably better to answer these basic
mechanistic questions. But certainly from a throughput standpoint, the nice
thing about these
molecular imaging tools is that
we can position ourselves to answer them.
One of the subtle things about this space, if you look at the number of
checkpoint plus EBRT publications and then compare it to the number of RPT plus
IO checkpoint, whatever combination therapies, EBRT is all the way up here,
RPT is down here, and a lot of it's just technical.
It's not the age of the fields.
A lot of this is just, these are just hard studies to run, because tissue's
radioactive for an extended period of time.
You got to let it decay down, and then you do your assays and hope that
everything's still viable.
So somewhere I see these molecular imaging tools slotting in.
It's just picking up the pace and also allowing us to answer questions in
people, where I think it might actually be a little bit faster and,
in some senses, more gratifying than trying to answer it in
mice with all the caveats with their models and everything. So yeah.
Yeah, it's great work. Thank you.
Yeah. I don't know if these guys have thoughts on that or yeah.
Any comments?
No, I agree. The trials are
difficult, even the monotherapy clinical trials.
I know you guys have some studies as well in this space.
So
I think that as we have more of these
radiopharmaceutical therapies, I think combinations are the future.
And there's been some ECTCN trials with PARP inhibitors or
DNA-damaging agents plus
different RLT agents.
But we'll see how that space evolves.
Great. Any additional questions from the audience?
All right, well, thank you. Oh, is there one here? Oh. Thank you.
Oh-oh, heading out. Okay. Well, thank you very much, everybody.
Thank you for your attendance. And again, take an eye
out for the San Diego meeting coming up with this theme in January.
And look forward to
seeing everybody then. Enjoy the rest of the day. Thank you.
I'd like to ask a couple of times, like we're doing
just on
the
floor.
But
it'd be
cool.